[Music]
we this week we've got IKEA cooking
shark race and alarm nightmare take it
away Tiffany [ __ ] it's always the
nightmare my alarm goes off I get it
that's true only yeah so for our first
story IKEA had this really cool concept
come out where it has these sheets it
has like these illustrations on it and
then you actually put your ingredients
on it and you roll it up and then you
mix it and you cook it and then you have
a meal so it's like the way you build
furniture but just replace the furniture
pieces for food pieces yeah kinda if you
don't really play sit on a mat when
you're building or you literally place
on a mat here
Oh your place when I met you roll it up
and you shake it and the dude comes up
difference between the paper and a
mixing bowl well this one is pretty
awesome
I got to see this because it sounds like
garbage to me so it looks like fish
it's called cook this page okay and so
they have this all over with food face
color ink okay that's so cool you place
like all your ingredients and they tell
you exactly what to put and then that's
for me because I'm not ravioli stupid
one I [ __ ] cook me too that's when I
saw eyes I'm like oh you both can use
this and start cooking now
yeah it cooks in the paper I don't think
they until I wear two of the u.s. so I
can't cook it but if I piers a worldwide
dude that looks so funny it honestly
looks like you just got a paper bag and
you threw food in it and you in there
okay [ __ ] chef not everyone is good
like you okay I saw I need that I need
that I suck
little child know your future that's
going to be terrible so they just buy
the ingredients and then you just
assemble it like that on the paper yeah
and so they're saying that all of these
recipes they're using the IKEA
food oh oh you could buy the ingredients
that I cream yeah I don't care like wow
that's great I ain't talking [ __ ] no
it's nothing I can make the baby do that
look and then they come out this large
shrimp
I don't turn on that crawfish not maybe
so that's tedious it's fun
I'll never learn to cook sounds like
here you do it baby
everyone around you who likes pickles
but those resting tomorrow what are
those black things on the right all over
things wow you're aza I personally think
this is stupid as [ __ ] but I can see why
a lot of people would need it you'll
needs it I mean it's are getting
radiator you know what you have you can
just go on YouTube and actually cook
some real [ __ ] it's so easy like that
funds like I think people all like me
where we just we don't think anything
about the kitchen is anywhere fun at all
like I don't want to cut in the kitchen
it's like a nightmare zone for me why
you play a microphone you have
nightmares
[Laughter]
you watch it like it's the word uh
you're alone I can try to make it fun
like this like I think I'm down
something like this like we're it's like
an activity to do it why I don't have to
like create and write I am like what
about like printing out just like a
recipe is following the recipe I mean I
can do that too but this is cool that's
exactly what this is tied up it's still
a little bit daunting especially when
they have to tell you how to like mix it
and you have to put this but yeah you
can follow it to a tee right but them it
like um I feel like you can you can get
scare at least I get scare I'm like [ __ ]
am i doing it the right way like it is
supposed to be correct but even less
figuring out on and yeah I see I I think
the I think it's a fun concept but it
looks like for children
my level of hiking is child by fear
adult uses I would laugh in their face I
feel like it's more work because then
you have to [ __ ] hit the strip and
align it perfectly and just waiting way
more time doing that instead of just a
guy on the ship and throwing it in a
bowl yeah I think this is like a program
that's going to eventually help you like
graduate out of thank you making
programs now
this is a warm-up we're saying first you
got a view food as fun for people that
don't see food as yeah that's exactly I
was chatting I see but I feel like - you
didn't even do this in my hand grab up
you know it's too much work because
there's a lot more work than actual
cooking as well speaking to because like
when you cook and you understand food
you don't need any of that [ __ ] just go
oh so did cooking your cuz it's hard to
lay out 36 pieces of shrimp like one by
one is it the shape of the shrimp on the
paper we had with your old CBS
definitely you might really like that
though I know this well what are you
gonna do when you can't find salmon in
that shape yeah and you can't cut it oh
she can't cut it or like on the first
one one if you want more ravioli pieces
engine yeah is it like she's gonna
follow that I'm going to do anything
else I'll just cook another page yeah
cook another page
yeah I mean I mean food too should just
be looked at something I like I said
everybody kind of looks it through like
a burden and I shouldn't be a burden
like it's honest it should be something
that's fun because it's a necessity of
[ __ ] life ahead of you
Dada you have to make cereal no cereal
but she calms down on the first bike
Robbie so funny like you make cereal and
then it catches on fire why do doesn't
go into my school is now their stuff and
easier cereal to make like rice and then
you can make I can do all of that I can
I'm like totally you know exaggerating
where I'm like I can't cook I just oh my
god you might like baking because baking
is very precise I [ __ ] up baking all the
time because in the middle of me reading
it online and you tried you to kitchen
you see control but then that means
sometimes you would have to adjust as
though depending what you're baking so
if you're like baking bananas like you
may know a baker you may not need as
much sugar as you think you need oh yeah
see all that science is accepted we need
to be knowledgeable you know like no you
just taste it but people get like
discouraged from cooking too because
like you'll cook one thing and it
doesn't turn out right they're like oh I
suck
it's not that case you just do it again
and again it's like anything that you do
is practice yeah like whatever the first
time I ever made lasagna but it was the
same [ __ ] that Joseph's like I don't
know what how much cheese how to put it
I put in the whole bag and I was like
hey I like cheese and then when I took
it out I put the spoon in and then
lifted the whole of [ __ ] it out I was
like I can't eat this what I threw it
away
it was so chapped it was terrible there
is such thing as like too much cheese
there's no such thing as too much cheese
I know someone that doesn't want to be
burned by the oil or be burned by like
hot water when they're like no lien it
[ __ ] jaw like I mean don't know like
two of the reasons why they don't want
to cook it because like they're just
afraid that the oil listen listen when
the water is hot you don't do this like
how do they post up in the oil I'm
trying to figure that [ __ ] out it's not
like you're throwing a dice if you don't
like it a lot next to burn me the other
day over the weekend we're cooking
together and I was like oh my god damn I
got [ __ ] shot on my chest
you gotta get those like covers oh well
the reason why that happens is like when
you fry things you can't have any water
on it so water hot oil it explode yes so
a lot of the times when you guys do my
people do like tempura fried and they
have like water on their hands or they
don't batter it right and they throw it
in it fit explode because of the water
content inside I was like when you do
like deep fried vegetables are like
shiso leaf or you know how they like
fight basil yeah but they throw the
table and they cover it because there's
so much moisture and it explodes
everywhere all right for our next story
it has been announced that Michael
Phelps will be racing a shark whoa
that's real ha ha I saw a tow
[ __ ] yeah wait is this shark like
retired super old 6 like is it [ __ ] up
not all have any questions as well
because I'm thinking like Harley in a
sentence uh by what's the logistics of
it how are they going to race and not
only that but shark some receipts are
just like straight about are they and
created for are they going to marinate
Michael selves before he jumps in I just
saw them going ready set go son
three on your mark
I know I'm so curious how this turns out
I like are you waited until the
countdown like I just forget going in I
didn't even fair Michael Phelps has a
lot of motivation of some tasks that's
what amazing well maybe they'll have a
divider but I obviously he's nothing to
I don't understand what the point of
this is what steps starting here come
here
yeah curious okay no so this is also
launched to the right channels annual
Shark Week which launches July 23rd so
that's what this whole I always hear
amazing things about shark yes and I
never watched a single one catch me up
with the [ __ ] shark where everyone
always part like and right now I'm
missing out I think from what I know
there's like this huge misconception
about sharks and how like vicious they
are and so people want to dispel that
yeah so Shark Week is where they just
educate people I think everyone loves it
though like Joe Rogan Jay Leno with the
rock like literally everyone rap today
because it's a brand on their own you
hear them on their own like they're like
off on like some Jimmy Kimmel show
they're out over here and with Channel
five News after they win a basketball
game yo shark we fish it it's like just
get you the most random places I agree
I've seen it once and it was pretty dope
because they have like they educate you
about sharks but then also like the the
cinematic shots that they have it just
looks so badass
oh no I don't like sharks I like them
from a distance I just don't like it
like you know what why people I said
let's swim when I like someone in the
house let me go check what that is I
respect sharks like I'm not if I see one
in the water I'm not going to try to
harpoon them you know but I'm not trying
to swim with them and try to dispel like
this belief about their life ishutin is
you know he's not lying we were in
Hawaii we actually were in a shark kids
swimming with sharks and he's like no
I'm not doing it no he overslept that
morning but conveniently over swellview
park immediately oversleep hey I told
you guys I wasn't going I slept with him
you know we don't take no for an answer
we're gonna bug you until you freakin
don't do it I just I just look like a
seal in the water so he has offered us
doesn't matter dude and they're
Galapagos sharks they're different from
tiger sharks and the guy also told me
the way we never hit the PO number three
where sighs you would aside was enriched
lunch yesterday look just like a whole
bunch of them like the K deck Santa
Claus
yeah hmm I like sharks the way Asian
people like them I want to eat them for
our last story there's this alarm clock
that has been stuck inside of a wall for
13 years and every day it goes off I
love this one why why why
Vasil who did that I know all the video
tip that's kind of scary
doesn't run on batteries what the [ __ ]
it does for 13 years the barrage of die
tell me what the battery oh my god I
want to buy those they say hard
Jerry Lynn says he dropped the clock
tied to a string
drop the clock vent set to go off ten
minutes later it would let him know
where to punch a hole in the living room
wall to pass a wire through for a TV
hookup as I was laying down all of us on
I heard cool funk as it came loose oh
that's not a real problem you know it's
still going to go off and it did he
couldn't pull up man but he figured
maybe three four months it'll run out of
battery that was in September of 2004
Jerry's wife Sylvia says the sudden ring
it can come as a jolt to
suspecting guests it starts with a soft
BBB BBB BBB all month I'm not going to
give you PTSD - and that will pull the
lever all in all it's just another clock
in the wall my god you hear that
make sure that that's [ __ ] nice
that's what I can't look like that dude
I know they lasted thirteen years so far
if you want to live a routine lifestyle
that's the perfect thing to do punch a
hole in your driver drywall and then put
an alarm clock in there and then seal it
so now you have to wake up at that time
every single day just move out that's
true how did he explain how it lasted
for so long I missed that part
oh you're just saying that he figured
that the batteries ran out would run out
like three or four months but it's been
13 years and still hasn't ha what kind
of battery are those it could just be
like you know those oh gee those like
flat looking alarm clocks those little
clocks that are like this then it looks
like a calculator doesn't take those
things last forever I was going to be 13
years now that's a great advertisement
for battery commercial and nice here 13
years and still going did he need any to
me Muriel of setting her alarm did like
excitement annoying [ __ ] thing on
earth so soon as she loves it he's like
yeah like this she knows that she has to
wake up at 10 a.m. right but she'll set
her alarm at 8 a.m. and it set like 17
hahahahaha it's the most [ __ ] annoying
thing ever
they all go off simultaneously like a
symphony so she'll set it up huh and she
wakes up at like 9:30
yes so we go the name
she have an iPhone the more she does it
on her phone and then she has another
one across from her bed when she has to
get up walk and turn it off but even
that doesn't work so she'll get back
haha so this is me so she has to go to
work early right I don't I wake up in
there's work time you know I'm just like
chillin and then it's like 7:00 a.m. it
goes off in like three Alon G oh okay
that's another one we have to do later
but it goes off again sweetie okay so
what got [ __ ] up like just stop but
you're up just gold is totally sexist
yeah it is off and off and talking it
and then she'll get up and they should
hit the one that's farther away with the
actual physical clock she goes back a
message there's a curse she goes back I
get it but she knows that if she hears
one she's not going to wake up but the
thing is I just wanna sleep more like
it's more disturbing for you to wake up
15 times yeah it doesn't help you rest
well when you're awaking conscious and
aware of that yes but when you're in
your bed and it's warm and comfortable
and you have like the best we've ever it
doesn't make any sense
I still don't get it because like let's
say if you have to be somewhere by 10:00
right and let's say the latest you have
to wake up and you've already map it out
and you know you can if you wake up by
9:00 you can be out of hospital
9-billion be there for me I would just
set my alarm at 9:00 so I can have the
best sleep all the way till 9:00 instead
of sleeping until 7:00 and having crazy
interrupted fear I'm not a morning
person so for you it's like as soon as
it goes off you can just spring out of
bed you know but from like 7:00 to 9:00
I would still rather have two hours
uninterrupted sleep versus have
interrupted two hours scientifically
speaking to it's more restful that way I
figured out now that well the moment she
gets out of bed I just put raw eggs
right there
she wakes up not on the same I mean I
don't exaggerate like that and put 15
alarms but I think from whatever time I
have to wake up and then 30 minutes
after that I have alarms in between like
every 10 minutes because I kind of do
that to I'll wake up I'll turn it off
I'm like okay I'm getting up and I'm not
don't go back two spaces and I know that
about myself as we give myself 30
minutes of waking up and running
wouldn't it be better if you just had
the extra 30 minutes to sleep it would
be better but it's really hard to get up
on the first after at all I mean I
agreed to with that and then also like
I'm actually paranoid because if I do
just set one alarm if I follow your your
way of doing it I like there's times
where like I slept through it I even
hear it yeah I mean - that's why I had
30 minutes of yeah because what I was
saying that was me really I thought was
odd is that she gets up and then she
sets it and then goes to sleep and I
don't do that I set up 30 minutes of
intervals of a lot of times I'm like you
know this button right you're screwed
yeah I've done that before like but it's
usually when I have less than six hours
of sleep so that's when it's like danger
zone oh [ __ ] I might sleep through the
whole thing so then I get up and I go I
got 15 minutes I'm just gonna sleep 15
minutes and then I wake up and then I
get up I get up to change it
yes yeah you never done that I I mean
usually - I mean if I have to go 17
times it's pretty excessive though yeah
you know once it's pretty okay
were you having to me though it's like I
did I do the LA thing now was just like
okay I know that it's going to take me
15 minutes to get here so I'll leave 15
minutes before this - doesn't work like
that we know you guys though but what
should happen is that you should plan to
leave a lot earlier because you don't
you might have to take a [ __ ] you might
have something that happened there might
be something you might have to attend to
but I'm like I'm smart I'm Elise I know
it's like 15 minutes but in this traffic
that something happens so I'm always
like thanks I look like so as you know
that once you leave extra early because
sometimes I like to give us heart
attacks nobama we should always wear it
smooth but me I'm always here ten
minutes late that's my thing you're good
today right we were the only times until
Isaac's okay I had a good night's sleep
last night and now the [ __ ] out let's
not you sexy [ __ ] useless
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you want to
follow us you could check out all our
[ __ ] links in the description box
below you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then that videos are up there
[Music]